- I've never seen Lost,
but it's a popular show. You asked for it,
so we're watching it and I'm grading it
based on the level of misinformation.
Chest compressions.
Bewoo.
(women screaming)
(engine whirring)
- Oh no.
- By the way if the engines are spinning,
you got to get out of the way.
They'll suck you right in.
- [Man On Lost] Help.
(engine whirring)
- I wish I had background
into this show to know
whether or not he's a doctor.
He could be a doctor,
he's dressed like one,
he's trying to help people,
he's heroic.
(engine whirring)
- [Man On Lost] Give me a hand.
Now.
- He knows how to work in teams,
interpersonal communication on point.
(man on Lost grunting)
- Ooh. Crush injuries are
quite dangerous because
as soon as you remove
whatever the object is on top
of the individual, that
area gets reperfused
and it can actually cause more problems.
Including if you fracture a
bone, you can develop something
known as a fatty embolism.
Where piece of the fat from
the inside of the bone marrow
actually travels to your heart and lungs,
causing major problems
and potentially death.
- All right, get him out of here.
Get away from the engine.
- Smart man. Get away from the engine.
Engines can explode.
- Please help me I'm having contractions.
- How many months are you?
- Oh, she's pregnant.
- I'm nearly 8 months.
- 8 months, okay.
- Oh, someone's doing chest compressions.
God awful chest compressions,
but at least they're trying.
I mean, he's lifting the hands
off of the person's chest,
while doing the chest
compression. That's problematic.
The hands got to stay there,
and you're not pumping with your elbows.
You're pumping with your body.
And remember you got to do it
a hundred beats per minute.
(engine whirring)
- Hey, hey, hey, hey. Get away from there.
- Oh no. The engine, I predicted it.
I felt it.
(engine explodes)
Oh and it exploded.
(engine exploding)
Shards, burning, ah problems.
- You're going to be okay.
Do you understand me?
- How does he know that?
The confidence on these shows astounds me.
You crashed a plane into an Island.
You don't know where you are.
You're lucky to be alive.
And he's like, don't worry I got this man.
- But you have to sit absolutely still.
- Oh really now?
Well, if she just sits
still, she'll be fine.
She just survived the plane crash.
- Hey you, come here.
I need to get this woman
away from these fumes.
- It's the fumes that are problematic.
- If her contractions
are currently closer than
three minutes apart call out for me.
- Call out for him? Because
he's going to be able to
rescue everybody.
There's explosive material
flying and falling from the sky
because engines are
exploding, but he's like
the fumes.
(sighs)
- Stop. Her heads not
titled far back enough,
you're blowing air into her stomach.
- Oh. Oh. Oh.
How about we don't breathe
into people's mouths anymore.
Just do the chest compressions
in order to buy time,
you definitely want to
pull the chin forward,
cause that does make it more accessible.
Like if you're doing an ambu bag,
you actually do want to
pull the chin up like that.
It helps the airway.
- Come on,
come on.
- Oh. And if you say, come
on, it actually doesn't help.
- Come on.
- And if you say it twice,
it also doesn't help.
- Come on.
- And if you say three
times, it also doesn't help.
Ooh, Ooh.
That's a serious laceration there.
That's going to require some sutures.
And why didn't, why is it
not bleeding, even though
it's open? You know in
the wilderness like this,
burning that wound, may
not be that terrible.
- Excuse me.
Did you ever use a needle?
- I made the drapes in my apartment.
- That's fantastic.
Listen, do you have a second?
I could use a little help here.
- He said, that's fantastic.
Please stop raising your arm.
Each time you do that,
you reopen the wound.
Just keep it down so the
wound can stay closed
and show her by rotating.
- Look, I'd do it myself. I'm a doctor.
- Oh, he is a doctor.
Look at Dr. Jack. You
know, in fact if his wound
is not bleeding out, I
would not be in a rush to
close it because wounds that are dirty,
and that's definitely a
dirty wound, should really
be allowed to heal by secondary healing.
Meaning that you don't do a
primary closure with sutures.
Because if you do a primary
closure with sutures,
you increase the rate of
having an infected wound
and he doesn't have antibiotics,
that's already problematic.
I think I would just kind of clean it out,
and allow it to heal by
not moving and letting the
area like chill.
(panting)
- He's not breathing.
- If a person's not
responsive and not breathing,
what do you do?
Chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compressions.
There you go.
Very poor quality chest compressions.
I give that a D minus.
Just cause he's at least
on the right spot, and
he's doing them, but poor for bad timing,
not deep enough, all wrong, wrong, wrong.
- Breathe Charlie. Come on breathe.
- I get the purpose of
doing chest compressions
is to try and revive somebody,
not because the chest
compressions actually
do something to help revive the person.
It just buys them time,
cause it circulates the blood
that's already in the vascular system.
Once the arteries deliver
the oxygen to your body parts
and then it's on its
way back, there's still
a little bit of oxygen left there.
So by squeezing the heart,
by doing proper chest
compressions, you're just
recirculating that blood
with its 10-20% of oxygen
still left inside of it.
And you kind of hope that
that blood circulating,
may trigger the heart to restart.
- Jack he's gone.
Jack. Stop. He's not.
- It's actually wise
to stop at this point,
because the brain has
been so long deprived
of oxygen, that it's
experiencing brain death.
That even if you restart the heart,
the person's not going to be functional,
they're not going to be able
to breathe on their own,
they're not going to be able to move.
And as a result on an Island,
that equals death or
incompatibility with life.
- Johnny.
- Oh, oh, oh.
Okay. Some coconuts or
something fell on his head,
but that didn't seem
like it's too traumatic.
Remember? Mechanism of injury
sometimes more important
than the injury itself.
Like when a patient comes in
and says their ankle hurts.
Yes. I want to look at it.
But most importantly, I want
to know how it happened.
What was the weight?
Did they fall?
How far did they fall?
Did they lose consciousness?
Was it witnessed?
How long were they unconscious?
All these questions allow us to picture
how much damage actually occurred.
- You're going to have to fix it.
- I'm not a doctor.
- You're a soldier.
What do people do when they get wounded?
- I mean, if the cut
is right above the eye,
do some sort of bandana
and tie it really tight,
cause the rest of the skull is okay,
and you can put pressure there.
It won't bleed and you'll be okay.
- Move the towel and tilt your head back.
- I, as a family medicine doctor,
board certified and all,
have no idea what's about
to happen.
- Oh, that need sutures.
Oh, he's going to burn it.
- This is not going to be pleasant.
- Is he going to explode?
- One. Two. Three.
- What about the rest of his face?
Wipe it off first.
Do not do this at home,
on an Island, anywhere.
He could have just lit the match,
and lit a leaf on fire and like patted it,
so at least it cauterized it a little bit.
My guy put gunpowder on it, like, oh
here's some T N T.
- I hate being sick.
- Me too.
- What do you think it is?
- It's food poisoning.
- What makes you think that?
- Got some cramping, dehydrated, nausea.
- Sounds like a gastroenteritis
could be from Giardia,
depends on his stool.
Let's see if he mentions it.
- You want to lift your shirt up?
- Appendicitis?
- It's your appendix Jack.
- Jack.
- So she touched him on
the right lower quadrant,
McBurney's point.
- Has it ruptured?
- How is he supposed to know that?
Can you imagine if I walk
into my patient's room,
hey, has your appendix ruptured?
- Right there?
- They're so fake injecting
him with the lidocaine,
it's literally like they're
just shooting it on his skin,
you actually have to go inside.
- Okay Jack. One more.
Try not to move.
(man grunting)
Just stay still.
- She's cutting his abdomen.
Just stay still. Would you?
Lol.
(giggling)
- Whose X-rays are those, outside?
Those are spinal x-rays
and they belonged to a man
about 40 years old.
And whoever he is, he has
a very large tumor on his
elafore vertebrae.
- It's weird that he knows the age.
I guess he's looking at it,
how much area in between
the vertebrae they are,
like if the disc spaces are preserved.
You can't know if that
person is 40, 30, 50, 20.
It's such a wild guess.
- Your neck, does it hurt?
- Any numbness in your
fingers and toes, like pins
and needles when your foot
falls asleep, but permanent?
- Because he knows you have a tumor,
he's asking about parasthesias.
- You have a tumor on your spine.
An aggressive tumor.
- You don't know what kind
of tumor someone has on their
spine off of an x-ray.
You've got a biopsy it,
you're not a superhuman.
You can't visualize
what the tumor is off an
X-ray. You could just see
that there's something
abnormal there, but it could
be multiple types of tumors.
If there's a tumor,
that's very, very visible,
that's oftentimes is not the case,
maybe you'll see it, but
you can't diagnose it.
You need further imaging.
You need further studies,
biopsies, et cetera.
(machine beeping)
(suspenseful music as
machine beeps faster)
- He's going into tachycardia. Why?
- What happened? Is he okay?
- His blood pressure's dropping.
Should he be bleeding like that?
- No. No he shouldn't.
(punches)
- Oh, oh, that is not good teamwork.
- You just made a small
incision in Ben's kidneys sack.
(chuckles)
Now if I don't stitch that
back up in the next hour,
he's dead.
- Yeah. He's dead now because
I think he's going into V-fib.
I don't know what he cut.
I don't know what he's doing.
All this is unethical.
Non-medically accurate.
This is a joke.
- No, no. Put him down up here.
- What happened?
- There was an accident, fell off a cliff.
- In situations like that, in a trauma,
you really want to rule
out internal bleeding,
because if a person's bleeding internally,
they are going to have moments to live.
If that, because you
need to deliver fluids,
you need to deliver blood.
And if you can't do that
on an Island, I don't know,
like you have no shot basically.
- I might need some water,
shirts, towels, anything that I can use to
stop the bleeding.
- I mean, if you're
bleeding on the outside,
odds are you're bleeding from the inside,
especially with a fall like that.
So towels aren't going
to do you much good.
- His lung just collapsed.
- How does he know that?
He doesn't have a stethoscope.
But if you put his ear to the chest,
or he saw that it wasn't
rising symmetrically,
maybe I'll buy it.
Maybe I'll buy it.
My guy looked at his
face and said his lung
collapsed. Jack has x-ray vision.
- Oh it burns.
- Closed fracture. Think we can set it.
- If his leg is turning blue,
which it looked like it was,
you really should do a
reduction where you put the bone
in its correct location.
Reason being is if the bone is
actively blocking circulation
to the lower foot, once you correct it,
you can get a reperfusion
injury and die just as
a result of that.
- Who's checking his
cervical spine for fractures?
There's just like tossing around his neck.
- He needs blood.
- What?
- Blood. Transfusion.
- I don't know how he's
going to do a makeshift I V.
- I was getting you this.
- A sea urchin?
- A hollow needle, sharpen
up the Pearson needle.
- Aren't those poisonous?
- It's perfect.
- What I don't understand is
what is he planning on doing
with this sea urchin spike?
Like he said just gonna just
spike the vein and then what?
- These types of transfusions
I've never seen work
before. I can't imagine
that it's actually working.
Also, I have no idea as
he's doing this transfusion,
how we know that he's
delivered enough blood.
How does he know how much
blood he's delivering?
I'm so used to ordering it
through a computer system,
not just from like, all right,
let me give him some
adequate amount of blood
until I guess I get dizzy and I pass out,
like I don't understand
how he's measuring this.
- It's not working.
- Blood's not the problem, it's the leg.
All the blood's pooling there.
Compartment syndrome.
He didn't get this injury from a fall,
something crushed his leg.
- Compartment syndrome
is really problematic
because when you have a crush
injury or really any kind
of issue where you're
getting intense inflammation
over a limb and it's circumferential
meaning that it happens
all around the limb.
It actually starts expanding and cutting
off circulation where
necrosis starts to have it.
And the treatment for this is
a fasciotomy where you actually go in
and make a cut in order to open
and allow the swelling to come out
so that the pressure
gets off of the arteries
and allows blood to flow again.
(coughing)
Again, this is surprise to no one.
He has internal injuries.
He's bleeding internally.
Keep pumping him full of blood.
Great, that maybe buys him some time.
But the reality is, as soon
as you pump it into him,
he bleeds it right back out internally.
This is why, if anyone ever
has an abdominal injury,
like let's say a
stabbing, a gunshot wound,
you literally have to
open up their abdomen,
and run their bowels
where you're making sure
that there's no area that
your patient is bleeding
out. Because if your patient bleeds out,
and you close them and
you think you're good,
and they continue bleeding, they can die.
- But I need you to push.
Okay?
- Okay.
- On the count of three.
Ready?
One, two, three, push.
Yeah, go ahead.
- You want to time to pushes
with the contractions,
so when the mom is starting
to feel the contraction
come on, you ask, you confirm,
and then you do a push with a count to 10.
And then once the contractions
over, you let the mom relax.
When the contraction comes
back, you repeat that process.
- I can see, I can see
the top of the head.
- The baby is crowning.
And it's ideal at the baby's
coming out head first.
If the baby's coming out breach,
that could be very problematic.
(woman pushing)
- Get the shoulders out,
get the shoulders out.
One at a time.
There's a baby. That is not a new born.
(laughs)
Classic with the baby's crying.
Good color, probably good Apgar scores.
Getting the baby right on
mom's chest, perfect form.
I like it.
Real doctor versus TV doctor.
I actually share a lot
of my really interesting
doctor patient stories.
So click on that and as always,
stay happy and healthy.
(electronic bounce music)